in this video we're going to talk about
how to write the equation of a quadratic
when you're just given three points so
we're going to work with a system of
equations involving three variables
three equations and I'm going to show
you how to work with this problem now if
you want to test yourself go ahead and
try it and then we'll go through it
together but remember when you're
writing the equation of a quadratic
which the graph is a parabola it's in
this form y equals ax squared plus BX
plus C our goal is to figure out what a
B and C are so let's go ahead and Dive
Right In so the first point here one
zero I'm going to put 0 in for our y
variable and I'm going to put 1 in for X
so if we do that we're going to get a
times 1 squared plus b times 1 plus C
now I'm going to do the same thing with
this second coordinate here the Y value
is negative 7. when the x value is 2. so
I'm going to put 2 in for x
and then same thing with the third point
we have negative 20 is equal to a times
3 squared plus b times 3
plus C so these are our three equations
and we want to solve this system now
first thing I'm going to do is kind of
simplify this down a little bit so 1
squared is one so this is just going to
be a
B times 1 is B
and c and I'm just going to flip this
equation so this is all equal to zero
now same thing with the second equation
2 squared is 4 times a is going to give
us 4A 2 times B is going to give us 2v
plus C is equal to negative seven and
the same thing with this third equation
3 squared is 9 times a which is 9A
plus 3B
plus C is equal to negative 20. okay so
now we've simplified a little bit we
want to pick one of the variables to
eliminate either the A's the B's or the
C's
I'm going to work with the C's because
you can see we just have one C in each
equation so I think that's going to be
the easiest and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take these first two
equations here okay and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to multiply this top
equation by negative 1.
and the reason I'm doing that I'll show
you in just a second is that's going to
flip the signs here it's going to make
this negative a negative B negative C
and 0 times negative 1 is still 0. this
equation here I'm just going to keep it
just like it is so that's going to be 4A
plus 2B plus C equals negative seven so
the reason I did that multiply
everything by negative 1 is because if
this is a negative C and this is
positive C
then when we add these equations
together what's going to happen to the
C's they're going to cancel out right so
negative 1A plus 4A is 3A 2B plus
negative B is 1B and 0 plus negative 7
is negative 7. okay so let's just circle
that for a moment now we use the first
two equations sometimes this is where
students go a little bit off track you
want to also use that third equation and
you want to stick with the same variable
that you were trying to eliminate in
this case we decide we're going to
eliminate the C's so we're going to
eliminate the C here using this third
equation we can combine it with the
second or with the first I tell you what
let's just combine this third equation
with this first equation that we
multiplied by negative one so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take this
equation here I'm going to bring it down
negative a minus B minus C is equal to
zero and I'm going to add these two
equations together and you can see the C
and the negative C cancel one another
out 9A minus 1A is 8A 3B minus B is 2b
and negative 20 plus 0 is negative 20.
so now look we're down to two variables
and two equations so this is the system
that we want to solve now do we want to
try to eliminate the A's or do we want
to try to eliminate the B's I think B is
going to be a little bit easier if we
can just make this negative 2B when we
add it to this equation the positive 2B
the B's will cancel so let's go ahead
and multiply this whole equation
by negative 2. so if we do that and
distribute negative 2 in here that's
going to give us negative 6A
negative 2B
and negative 2 times negative 7 is
positive 14. so now when we add these
two equations together you can see the
B's are canceling we're getting 8A minus
6A is 2A negative 20 plus 14 is negative
6 and you can see now we're down to just
one variable one equation
so you can see how we went from three to
two to one now if we divide both sides
by 2
you can see that a is coming out to
negative 3
and then what we want to do now is we
want to work our way backwards so if a
is negative 3 we can put it into one of
the equations that has just two
variables so let's just put it into this
one over here so that's going to be 3
times negative 3
plus b equals negative seven
so that comes out to negative nine plus
b equals negative seven add nine to both
sides and you can see that b is coming
out to positive two so now we have a and
b we want to work back to the
three variable equations one of the
original ones
I'll just do this top one right here so
this comes out to let's see a which is
negative three
plus b which is two
plus C which we don't know and that is
going to equal zero so we have negative
one plus C equals zero add one to both
sides and you can see see that c is
coming out to one that's hard to say so
now you can see we've got our a b and c
all we have to do now is put it into for
a b and c here and that's going to be
the equation of our quadratic so let's
go ahead and do that so that comes out
to y equals negative 3 x squared plus
two X plus one
and that's the equation of our Parabola
so great job if you were able to get
that one on your own if you want to see
another example I'll put a link to a
video right there where I talk about
similar problems just like these so if
you want more practice follow me over
that video right there and we'll get
some more practice